Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. There's one thing you men will be able to say when this war is over and you get back home. 30 years from now, when you are sitting by your fireside with your grandson on your knee and he asks,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目以及加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告音频并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是 Apple Podcasts App，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。这场战争结束、你们安全回家时，你们这些年轻人能说上一件事。30年后，当你坐在炉火旁，膝上坐着孙子，他问你：
What did you do in the Great World War II? You won't have to cough and say, Well, your granddaddy shuffled shit in Louisiana. No, sir. You can look him straight in the eye and say, son, your granddaddy rode with a great third army and a son of a goddamn bitch named George Patton. All right, you sons of bitches. You know how I feel. I'll be proud to lead you wonderful guys in battle anytime, anywhere. That's all. Tom, that was George C. Scott as General Patton.
你在伟大的第二次世界大战中做了什么？你不用支支吾吾地说，哦，你爷爷在路易斯安那州铲屎。不，先生。你可以直视他的眼睛说，孩子，你爷爷曾跟随伟大的第三集团军南征北战，跟随一个名叫乔治·巴顿的狗娘养的将军。好了，你们这群狗娘养的。你们知道我的感受。无论何时何地，我都为能带领你们这群了不起的家伙作战感到骄傲。就这样。汤姆，刚才那是扮演巴顿将军的乔治·C·斯科特。
And George Patton, the great U.S. general in World War II, he's commonly remembered, isn't he, as one of these sort of titanic leaders, these larger-than-life commanders who who through the force of their personality, and indeed, their stirring rhetoric as beautifully rendered in that impersonation, they roused their men, they dragged their men through the hell of battle to victory. And you and i have only just been talking about another great commander in horatio nelson um so are you a great believer tom in individual leaders in history going you know think back to the romans and do you think they matter well i think it depends oh god what an evasive note on which to start well no but there are two different styles of war aren't there
而作为二战中伟大的美国将军，乔治·巴顿通常被人们记住，不是吗，他就像那种泰坦式的人物、那些传奇般的指挥官，他们凭借个人魅力的力量，甚至还有刚才那个模仿秀中精彩呈现的慷慨激昂的辞令，鼓舞了手下的士兵，拖着他们穿过战斗的地狱走向胜利。你和我刚才恰好在讨论另一位伟大的指挥官霍雷肖·纳尔逊，嗯，那么，汤姆，你坚信历史上的个人领袖能发挥作用吗，比如回想一下罗马人，你认为他们重要吗？嗯，我觉得这得看情况。噢，天哪，这是一个多么含糊的开场白啊。好吧，不，但战争有不同的风格，不是吗？
there's the style of war that privileges dash um and and celerity and tactical acumen and all that kind of stuff. And then there's a style of war that privileges the grind, the heft, the remorselessness. So I'm thinking of comparing Alexander and Caesar, which is a contest that we have already discussed. We do public events. We're asked that all the time. So I would say that Alexander obviously had, he had his phalanx and he had his cavalry and that was very well honed. But I would say that it was, you know,
有一种战争风格特别强调冲劲、迅速、战术敏锐度以及诸如此类的东西。然后还有一种战争风格，强调的是死磨硬泡、厚重感和冷酷无情。所以我在想要把亚历山大大帝和恺撒做个对比，这是我们已经讨论过的一个话题。我们做过公开活动，大家总是问我们这个问题。所以我想说，亚历山大显然拥有，他拥有他的方阵和骑兵，这是经过千锤百炼的。但我想说的是，
his conquest of the Persian empire wouldn't have happened without Alexander. Whereas the Romans, I think we were always going to conquer gaul because that's the way the legions functioned institutional machinery and so that's what and that that particularly became the case once augustus had established um uh the legionary system these this kind of essentially professional army which i think is why after the age of caesar there are no kind of box office roman generals that people remember because they don't need them because they don't need them
如果没有亚历山大，他征服波斯帝国的伟业就不会发生。而对于罗马人，我认为我们无论如何都会征服高卢，因为军团就是那样运作的，那是制度化的机器，所以就是这样，而且在奥古斯都建立——呃——军团制之后，这种情况尤其明显，这种基本上属于职业军队的制度，我想这就是为什么在恺撒时代之后，人们记不住任何那种票房号召力般的罗马将军，因为他们不需要，因为根本不需要。
and so this is prompted by the publication of a brilliant new book called command how the allies learn to win the second world war by al murray co-host of we have ways our sister podcast and i was reading it and i thought you, coming off the back of our episodes on Trafalgar, Nelson is a titanic figure. Everyone in Britain has heard of Nelson, even if you know nothing about history. And Al has written a series of biographies of commanders in the Second World War. And I would say the only one I really know anything about is Montgomery. There are 10 of them.
所以这是由一本名为《指挥：盟军如何学会赢得第二次世界大战》的精彩新书的出版所引发的，作者是阿尔·默里，他是我们姊妹播客《我们有办法》的联合主持人。我在读这本书时心想，紧接着我们在特拉法加和纳尔逊身上的节目之后，纳尔逊是一个泰坦式的人物。英国的每个人都听说过纳尔逊，即使对历史一无所知的人也是如此。阿尔写了一系列关于二战指挥官的传记。而我想说，我真正了解的唯一一个大概只有蒙哥马利了。书里总共有十位指挥官。
And so Patton is included. I don't really know anything about Patton. Just lots of shouting, I think, Tom. That's basically my impression of Patton. Your impression of Patton was, of course, of George C. Scott. He famously had a high-pitched voice, so it would be more like, you sons of bitches!
所以巴顿也被收录其中。我其实对巴顿一无所知。我想，基本上就是各种大喊大叫吧，汤姆。这就是我对巴顿的基本印象。你对巴顿的印象，当然是来自乔治·C·斯科特。他出了名地有着一副尖嗓听起来更像是：你们这群狗娘养的！
Yeah. To be honest with you you to be brutally honest i've never i've never actually seen their film so that was just it was the impression of a poster so what i learned from it is that that um pattern had a voice like a neanderthal you goddamn son of a bitch that's how he spoke so you got it very wrong uh let's let's ask the big question right at the outset do commanders matter at all oh um i think they absolutely do and and i think your example of nelson speaks to uh in the end what a great commander can do which is that he he'll be he'll inherit a system he'll be gifted gifted a mechanism for waging war,
对。老实说，说句大实话，我其实从来没看过他们的电影，所以那只是海报留下的印象。我从中了解到的是，嗯，巴顿的声音听起来像个尼安德特人：你这个该死的狗娘养的！他就是这么说话的，所以你完全搞错了。呃，让我们在一开始就提出这个宏大的问题：指挥官到底重要吗？噢，嗯，我认为他们绝对重要，而且我认为纳尔逊的例子说明了——归根结底，一个伟大的指挥官能做什么，那就是他会继承一个系统，他会被赋予一套进行战争的机制，
and then it's his ability to sort of, in vital eyes, a word, but to take hold of it and get it to work as efficiently as it possibly can. And when you talk about, you know, Monty being the only chap you've ever heard of out of this bag of people, Tom. That's not quite true. It's not quite true, but it is also completely one that I understand. It is also completely understandable. And Monty's sort of representative of this. One of the things I think that happens culturally after the Second World War is we sort of go,
然后就是他的能力，嗯，让它焕发生机，或者说，掌控它并使其尽可能高效地运转。当你说，你知道，在这一堆人里，蒙蒂是你唯一听说过的家伙，汤姆。这不太准确。这不太准确，但我也完全能理解。这也是完全可以理解的。蒙蒂在某种程度上正是这种现象的代表。我认为二战后在文化上发生的事情之一是，我们某种程度上会觉得：
God, that was horrible. And we shove it aside and try not to remember it as a society. We'll try to ditch, certainly the people that made us do terrible things to win the war. And Monty's peculiar in that he stands out as a figure that is remembered,
天哪，太可怕了。作为一个社会，我们把它推到一边，尽量不去回忆它。我们肯定会试图抛弃那些为了赢得战争而逼我们做可怕事情的人。而蒙蒂之所以特殊，是因为他作为一个被人们记住的人物脱颖而出，
but is also vilified. And I think for that reason, that's sort of his function after the war. He becomes a sort of lightning rod for how objectionable the war was as an experience for a civilian population, because he's a citizen commander. But morale was his central thing. The one thing he wanted to concentrate on when he took over 8th Army in August of 1942 was fixing the morale. So taking the machine and getting it to function properly by grabbing people and improving their attitude to how they were going to go about fighting. That's his thing. That's his gift. In the way that Nelson, you know, would cause hussars everywhere he went, that was what Monty was going for but also al i learned from your book uh he was concerned to sort out um venereal
但同时也受到了极大的诋毁。我认为出于这个原因，这在某种程度上就是他在战后的作用。他成为了一个避雷针，反映了对于平民百姓而言，战争作为一种经历是多么令人反感，因为他是一个平民指挥官。但士气是他的核心关切。1942年8月他接手第八集团军时，最想集中精力做的一件事就是修复士气。也就是接管这台机器，通过激励人们并改善他们对待战斗的态度，使其正常运转。这就是他的拿手好戏。这是他的天赋。就像纳尔逊，你知道的，无论走到哪里都会迷倒众生一样，蒙蒂追求的就是这个。不过阿尔，我从你的书中了解到，呃，他极其关注如何整顿性病，简直到了痴迷的程度，我的意思是，坦白说吧——所以他写了一份备忘录，里面谈到一个男人在甜菜地里和一个女人鬼混——是的，我的意思是，甜菜是怎么回事？根茎类蔬菜？那里到底发生了什么？蒙哥马利的一大特点是，当你开始阅读、了解他时，我认为你需要对他的话略打折扣，而不是把他所有的话都当作骇人听闻的圣旨来全盘接受。他是个多么可怕的家伙啊！他有着一种奇怪的、顽皮的幽默感，我认为在这份备忘录里，我开篇提到的整个事件，其实就是为了试探这样一种观点：1939年、1940年的英国军队，就像英国的政治建制一样，卷入了一场他们其实并不怎么当回事的战争。
disease to the point of obsession i mean so let's be frank so he he writes this memo in which he talks about a man who has a woman in a beetroot field yes i mean what's the thing about beetroots the root vegetables what's going on there one of the things about montgomery is he actually has when you start to read read him i think are prepared to take him with a little bit of a pinch of salt rather than take him all appallingly seriously what a ghastly fellow he is he's this strangely imp he has this strangely impish sense of humor and i think that's in that memo this whole incident which i opened the book with is is really to try and sort of prod at the idea that the British army in 1939, 1940, like the British political establishment, has got itself into a war it's not particularly serious about.
他们以为战争可能会不了了之，根本不用真的去打仗。蒙蒂给他的师写信。他当时掌管步兵第三师。他给师里的军官写信说，你知道的，咱们的小伙子们——因为当时正值静坐战，他们没有装备来进行适当的演习和训练。而且他们身在法国。美丽的法国。他们身在法国。嗯，而且他们的父辈也曾在法国待过。这是需要记住的另一件事。
And it thinks will probably fizzle out without having to do any fighting. And Monty writes to his division. He's in charge of the 3rd Infantry Division. He writes to his divisional officers saying, you know, our lads, because it's the phony war and they've got no kit to exercise and train with properly. And they're in France. La Belle France. And they're in France. Well, and their fathers were in France. It's the other thing to remember.
我敢肯定，有些父亲曾把小伙子们拉到一边，告诉他们当年和当地人在一起时度过了多么美妙的时光。所以他担心，你知道的，手下男兵的性健康。毕竟这是梅毒的年代，当时还没有治疗梅毒的抗生素，所以这其实是件极其严肃的事情。但当然，蒙蒂以他自己的风格，写了一份类似——我不知道，我的意思是按现代标准来看，这是一份完全无害的备忘录——但在当时却显得有点厚颜无耻。好吧，所以——而随之而来的反应是，艾伦·布鲁克，也就是他的上司，措辞极其下流，以至于英国陆军和皇家海军的高级随军牧师都向副官长投诉了。是的。而副官长，你知道的，他掌握着你的职业生涯，
I'm sure some of the fathers have taken the lads to one side and told them what a fantastic time they had with the locals. And so he's worried about, you you know the sexual health of his men and this is the age of syphilis after all this is pre pre-antibiotic cure for syphilis so this is a this is actually terribly serious but of course Monty in his own in his own style writes a sort of uh I don't know i mean by modern standards it's an entirely anodyne memo but but for the time a little bit cheeky well so and and the response is to alan brooke who's his commander worded in such obscene language that both the cov and rc senior chaplains complained to the adjutant general yep and the adjutant general will you know he he controls your career
嗯，如果他觉得你格格不入，他就会把你炒鱿鱼。蒙蒂的特点在于，他的职业生涯中——因为他认为自己是两战间期的一名职业军人，而在那个时期，人们相当坚决地不想进行任何职业化的军事训练，更不用说——欧洲的——我讨厌当前流行的“战争作战”（war fighting）这个词——但他们对在欧洲打仗毫无兴趣，确实毫无胃口，而他偏要谈论这个。他想讨论你该如何去打仗。所以在各种军官食堂里，他面对面试官时总是非常直率，正如你所知，他发现自己身处那样的环境中。但基本上到1939年，他们得到了这家伙，他超级高效，工作极为出色，对新思想持开放态度，
um he'll fire you if he thinks you're not if you're not fitting in and the thing about montes he has had a career where because he regards himself as a professional soldier in a in the interwar era where people are quite determined not to do any professional soldiering and certainly not you know european i hate the word war fighting that's current but they're not interested in fighting a war in europe certainly they've no appetite for it and he's talking he wants to talk about that he wants to discuss how you might do that so he's he's very detroit during the interviewers in in the various messes he in you know that he that he finds himself in but basically by 1939 they've got themselves this guy he's super efficient he's excellent at his job he's open to ideas and he's
而且他还有一种“要么听我的，要么滚蛋”的态度。他差一点因为关心手下士兵的健康而被炒鱿鱼，这在我看来简直是荒谬绝伦。他的原话是“水平方向的恢复”（horizontal refreshment），没错，就是那个。嗯，这让他的上司感到惊慌。不过无论如何，让我们把镜头稍微拉远一点，抱歉，在我们消失在形形色色蒙蒂式的兔子洞之前，聊一聊——是的。所以，要成为一名将军，成为一名二十世纪四十年代二战中的指挥官，也就是汤姆和我一开始讨论的那些例子，
also got a sort of my way or the highway attitude and he comes close to being fired for caring about the health of his men which just strikes me as you know preposterous essentially the phrase is horizontal refreshment that's right that's um that alarms his superior but anyway let's pull back the camera a bit sorry and talking a sort of uh before we sort of disappear down lots of mon Monty-shaped rabbit holes. Yeah. So to be a general, to be a commander in the Second World War in the 1940s, so the examples that Tom and I talked about right at the beginning,
纳尔逊、亚历山大、尤利乌斯·恺撒，这些人都在冒着巨大的身体风险。是的。而且他们身处——你知道的，在纳尔逊的例子中，他阵亡了。亚历山大，你知道的，他会率领骑兵冲锋在前，诸如此类。到了四十年代，当将军大概与历史此前绝大多数时期的军事指挥官完全不同了，也许威灵顿公国时期除外，但在那之前——所以这些人是在进行管理，因此他们必须是官僚式的管理者，
Nelson, Alexander, Julius Caesar, these are all people who are taking enormous physical risks. Yes. And who are in, you know, Nelson's case, he's killed. Alexander's, you know, he will lead the cavalry he will charge ahead all that sort of thing then the 1940s being a general is presumably completely different from being a military commander at most previous points in history maybe not the duke of wellington but before that so these are people who are managing so they have to be bureaucratic managers
同时也得是某种足球经理、战术家，所有这些角色集于一身。是的，我的意思是，是的，绝对是这样。摆在他们办公桌上的那些文件，他们真正必须擅长的核心事务之一就是管理参谋部，拥有一支——因为我们已经不再是那种，你知道的，威灵顿在战场上嘬着牙花子计算各个方阵何时能同时抵达同一地点，以及所有诸如此类的……他知道他的轻步兵以多快的速度通过某些地形，他的轻骑兵能做什么，重骑兵能做什么。
as well as kind of football managers tacticians all these kinds of things yes i mean yes absolutely the stuff going over their desk one of the real things they have to really be good at is running a staff is having a staff that because we've moved away from you know wellington sort of sucking his teeth on a battlefield and calculating how fast the formations will all arrive in the same place and all that sort of... He knows how fast his light infantry can make their way across certain terrain and what his light cavalry can do and what his heavy cavalry can do.
他在脑海里飞速运算着各个部队的位置……我们已经不再是那种模式了，现在你拥有一个参谋部。所以关键在于拥有一个优秀的参谋长。也就是说，要拥有一群你能驾驭得住的优秀人才。这与其他任何事情一样至关重要。蒙蒂的参谋长，所以关键在于拥有一个能驾驭得住的优秀人才。这与其他任何事情一样至关重要。蒙蒂的参谋长弗雷迪·德·甘加（Freddie de Guingand）是个管理他那反复无常的将军的天才。所以，这关乎如何运作参谋部。
And he's sort of running the numbers in his head as to where... We've come away from there and you have a staff. So it's about having a good chief of staff. So it's about having good people that you can manage. It's as crucial to it as anything else. Monty's chief of staff, so it's about having good people that you can manage. It's as crucial to it as anything else. Monty's chief of staff, Freddie de Ganga, was a brilliant man at managing his sort of mercurial general. But so it's about running a staff.
这关乎如何在部下面前保持辨识度，这成为二战将领职责中非常非常重要的一部分，因为你进入了一个，你知道的，真正的海量大众传媒时代，投射公众形象变得极其重要。当然，你知道的，我们谈到了巴顿。我认为你模仿海报的举止本身就说明了巴顿在向人们塑造形象方面是多么成功，以至于你知道他长什么样，你知道的，而且他，你知道的，他想成为某种美式汉尼拔。他希望你在标志性的意义上去看待他。所以你得，你得应付很多盘子。所有的英国将领都是一战时期过来的人或者帝国官员，因此都经历过身体上的危险。
It's about being recognisable to your men becomes a very, very big part of Second World War generalship because you're entering the age of, you know, proper mass media and projecting an image becomes incredibly important. And of course, you know, we talked about Patton. The reason you were doing an impression of a poster, I think, tells you how successful Patton was in delivering his image to people that you know what he looks like, you know, and he, you know, he's, he wants to be a sort of an American Hannibal. He wanted you to think of him as in an iconic sense. So you've got, you've got lots of plates to spin. All of the British generals were First World War people or imperial people, so will have experienced physical danger.
勇敢是他们本色的一部分。你知道的，蒙哥马利在1915年的一场战场上被子弹击穿肺部，夜里被遗弃在战场上等死，诸如此类。谁是那个获得维多利亚十字勋章（VC）的人？哦，那是弗雷伯格（Freyberg）。是的，弗雷伯格。弗雷伯格被称为“火蜥蜴”，丘吉尔称他为“火蜥蜴”，
And bravery was a part of who they were. You know, Montgomery was shot through the lung on a battlefield on 9-15 and left for dead overnight and all that sort of stuff. Who's the one who had the VC? Oh, that's Freyberg. Yes, Freyberg. Freyberg, who's known as the salamander churchill calls him the salamander
我不会在这个播客里模仿丘吉尔的语气，因为那个地盘已经被牢牢占据了，但他在一战加里波利战役中负伤数十次，游上岸，还光着身子——你说是光着身子？是的，嗯，对，我的意思是，总比被军服拖下水要好吧，我想。穿着全套装备到处游泳简直是疯了，汤姆。我可不会光着身子。我坚持要穿全套装备。纳尔逊式的礼仪。
and i'm not going to wade in with a churchill impression on this podcast because that turf is firmly stamped out but he he is wounded scores of times in the first world war at gallipoli swims ashore and puts fake naked you say naked yes well yeah i mean rather than be dragged down by your tunic, I suppose. You'd be mental to be swimming around in all your kit, Tom. I would not go naked. I would insist on wearing full kit. Nelsonian decorum.
我是一名英国军官。我要穿着军服死去。不过是的，弗雷伯格极其勇敢。在二战第一次阿拉曼战役中，他再次负伤。这会赋予他某种地位吗？我的意思是，这会赋予他某种权威吗？这赋予了他地位，也赋予了他权威，但在枪林弹雨中表现得无比勇敢与真正能够指挥一场战役之间，这两者是如何交织的呢？嗯，是的，因为你说他很迟钝。我可能是在意译。我想你是说他不太聪明，或者类似的话。嗯，我认为问题就在于，我试图以一种微妙而细腻的方式来处理这个问题。
I'm a British officer. I die with my uniform on. But yes, he was phenomenally brave, Freyberg. And he's wounded again in the Second World War during the First Battle of Alamein. Does that give him a status? I mean does that give him an authority? It gives him a status and it gives him an authority but where the crossover between being phenomenally brave under fire and actually being able to run a battle. Well yes because you say he was thick. I may be paraphrasing. He wasn't very clever I I think you say, or something. Well, I think this is the problem is I've tried to handle that in a nuanced and subtle way.
他在克里特岛战役中的表现就是个例子，尽管这相当糟糕，因为他其实知道会发生什么。那么，请为那些可能对克里特岛战役一无所知的人讲讲吧。所以，对于那些对克里特岛战役一无所知的人来说，克里特岛战役属于，你知道的，二战前三年的战事，对英国人来说直到1942年8月才真正有所转机。我们有办法让你开口。我们称他们为“杜克部队”（Duke Forces），因为它是自治领（Dominions）、英国（UK）和帝国（Empire）的缩写，因为我们需要一个顺口的缩写。你们是一个包容性很强的播客。
He's handling it at the Battle of Crete, although it's pretty woeful because he knows what's going to happen. So just tell us about the Battle of Crete for those who may know nothing about it. So for those who know nothing about the Battle of Crete, the Battle of Crete falls into the, you know, the first three years of the Second World War until really August of 1942 for the British. And we have ways of making you talk. We call them the Duke Forces because it's Dominion's UK and Empire because we wanted a handy acronym. You're an inclusive podcast.
不，不，不。我们很具有帝国作风，唐。好吧，好吧。噢，那完全是另一回事了。那是完全不同的一种包容。约瑟夫·张伯伦式的包容。好吧，就是这样。完全如此。
No, no, no. We're being imperial, Don. Okay, okay. Oh, that's a very different story. It's a very different kind of inclusion. Joseph Chamberlain's idea of inclusion. Well, there you go. Exactly.
因此，1940年在法国发生的事情绝对堪称奇耻大辱，紧接着在1940年底对意大利人取得了伟大胜利，即“罗盘行动”（Operation Compass），当时奥康纳将军（General O'Connor）包围了意大利人，俘虏了数十万意大利人，那进展得极其顺利；然后英国人卷入了希腊战事，结果却极其、极其糟糕。当他们在1941年5月仓皇逃离希腊时，克里特岛成了希腊最后剩下的阵地。丘吉尔让自己陷入了一种执念，认为你需要保卫希腊，因为它是君主国，因为它是民主的发源地，因为它们是我们在欧洲大陆上仅存的高贵盟友，出于诸如此类的丘吉尔式的原因。军队心想：“噢，天哪，好吧”，然后再次遭到惨败。所以当你们来到克里特岛时，克里特岛成了最后留下的阵地，
So the absolute ignominium of what happens in france in 1940 is then followed by there's a great victory against the italians in late 1940 operation compass when uh general o'connor rounds up the italians hundreds of thousands of italians captured that goes terribly well and then the british get involved in in greece and it goes terribly, terribly wrong. And as they're scuttling out of Greece, come May 1941, Crete is the last bit of Greece left. Churchill has tangled himself up in the idea that you need to defend Greece, because it's a monarchy, because it's where democracy came from, because they are our sole noble ally left on the continent of Europe and sort of Churchillian reasons. The army goes, oh, Christ, all right, and is then soundly defeated again. And so when you come to Crete, Crete's the last bit left
位于，你知道的，欧洲大陆和非洲大陆之间，基本上是兵家必争之地。而德国人决定——而且这是在他们脑海中牢牢想着当年6月、7月的“巴巴罗萨”计划的情况下——德国人决定他们要做的是占领克里特岛。克里特岛上集结了一批杜克部队，他们其实并不是为了保卫岛屿而设计的，但人数众多，而且他们破译了德国空军的密码，因为德国空军在纪律上非常松懈，他们每天都发送天气预报以及诸如此类的信息，所以你会一遍又一遍地得到相同的内容，这正是密码破译员们梦寐以求的，他们破解了德国空军的密码，知道德国人正计划用伞兵部队占领克里特岛，他们将会在克里特岛这里登陆，这就是他们的登陆地点，这就是他们计划实施的方式，
between, you know, the continent of Europe and the continent of Africa that's up for grabs, basically. And the Germans decide, and this is, you know, with Barbarossa very firmly in their mind for June, July that year, the Germans decided what they're going to do is capture Crete. And there's an assemblage of Duke forces on Crete isn't they're not really designed to defend the island but there's tons of them and they crack the Luftwaffe ciphers because the Luftwaffe are very lax at disciplining because they send weather forecasts every day and all that sort of stuff so you get you get the same stuff over and over again which is what code breakers want and they pop open the Luftwaffe cipher and they know that the Germans are planning to capture Crete using parachute soldiers they're going to land on Crete here's where they're going to do it here's how they're going
并且英国人对德国人在1940年使用伞兵的方式进行了深入研究，即占领一个机场然后进行增援。所以他们确切地知道将要发生什么。他们确切地知道什么时候会发生。他们有时间表，有目标，对将要发生的事情了如指掌。弗雷伯格对将要发生的一切了如指掌，但他并没有真正抓准如何应对这一威胁。他也极力想要保护这样一个秘密：他拥有“超级机密”（Ultra）授权，并且知道自己已经事先得到了警告。所以他没有大张旗鼓地去保卫机场，
to do it and the British had made a great study of what the Germans had done in 1940 with their parachutists, which is to capture an airfield and reinforce. So they know exactly what's going to happen. They know exactly when it's going to happen. They have the timetable, they have the objectives, they know everything about what's going to happen. Freyberg knows everything about what's going to happen, but he doesn't really grip how he deals with the threat. He also is desperate to protect that he has ultra clearance and that he knows that he's been forewarned. So he sort of doesn't make a big thing of defending the airfields,
尽管这显然是你本该去做的事。因为他基本上不想泄露他们知情的消息。是的，完全如此。嗯，尽管这也是某种为他辩护的论点之一。让德国人赢这一场，免得他们发现情报泄露。没错，没错。
although that's obviously what you would do. Because he doesn't want to give away that they know, basically. Yeah, exactly. Well, although that's one of the arguments that sort of defends him a little. Let the Germans win this one so they don't know a broken neck. Exactly, exactly.
关键是，人们确实会围绕“恩格玛”（Enigma）的故事陷入纠结，因为它是二战中那些引人入胜的故事之一，在很长一段时间后浮出水面，显得那么干净利落，不涉及轰炸城市，
And the thing is, people do get themselves in tangles around the Enigma story because it's one of the compelling Second World War stories that emerged a lot later that sort of clean, doesn't involve firebombing cities,
你知道的，牧师住宅里聪明的怪才们破解了凶险的德国密码。它更符合现代人的审美。所以你看著“恩格玛”心想，哦，好吧，你知道的，那个密码显然，那就是当时的情况。他们在保护它。但也有可能实际上他只是单纯地把事情搞砸了，因为他能力不够。
you know, clever boffins in a vicarage figuring out the fiendish German code. It sits more comfortably with a more contemporary sensibility. And so you look at the Enigma and you think, oh, well, you know, that code's obviously, that's what's going on there. They're protecting it. But it may be that actually he just simply mishandled things because he wasn't up to it.
不过，正如我刚才所说，他也确实继承了一个乌合之众般的烂摊子。他们的无线电不过关，内部通信无法正常工作，也没有多少火炮。但是，如果你有一个机场，旁边有一座俯瞰它的山丘，你却不派人占领这座俯瞰它的山丘，这就有点——嗯，相当匪夷所思了。而我，你知道的，我是一名喜剧演员，我也能看出他在处理这件事上的失误——所以，我认为在人们之中的看法——我知道你们《我们有办法》播客的听众对二战无所不知——但在我们这些对二战并非无所不知的人当中，这种看法是，
He also did inherit, however, like I said earlier, a sort of ragtag thing. Their radios weren't up to scratch and their internal communications didn't work and they didn't have very much artillery but but what you do if you've got an airfield you've got a hill overlooking it is you don't leave the hill overlooking it it's um fairly straightforward and i you know i'm a comedian i can tell that this thing about this thing about him mishandling it so the the perception I would say among people I mean I know your listeners on the we have ways podcast to know everything about the second world war but the perception among those of us who don't know everything about it
你可能会觉得这是一个绝对荒谬的刻板印象，但我猜大多数人的想法是，英国将领，至少在战争初期，都是些略显不负责任、装腔作势、穿着肥大裤子、名不副实的业余爱好者。我猜这种看法，尤其是对我们的海外听众来说，会是这样的：美国人随后加入了进来，他们思想顽固（方脑袋），而且冷酷无情、务实、现代化。是的。他们抽雪茄，而英国人穿着套头衫、抽着烟斗。
and you'll probably think this is an absolutely ludicrous stereotype but I would guess this is what most people think is that the British generals, certainly at the beginning of the war, were sort of slightly feckless, foppish, massive trousers, you know, out of their depth amateurs. And I guess the perception, especially among our overseas listeners, would also be then the Americans come in and they've got kind of square heads and they are unbelievably ruthless and hard-nosed and modern. Yeah. They smoked cigars and the British wore jumpers and smoked pipes.
留着细小的胡子。我猜这是一个荒谬且完全不准确的看法。但其中有没有一丝真相呢？是的，后半部分确实有一点真相。美国人非常自觉地打造了一支崭全新军，并以新政现代化精神全盘接受了它。后半部分——美国人非常自觉地打造了一支崭全新军，并以新政现代化精神全盘接受了它，
Thin moustaches. I'm guessing that this is a preposterous and indeed utterly inaccurate. But is there an element of truth in it? Yeah, there's definitely a grain of truth in the second half of that. The Americans very self-consciously create a brand new army and embrace it in the sort of spirit of New Deal modernity. second half of that that the americans very self-consciously create a brand new army um and embrace it in the sort of spirit of new deal modernity and um it's no coincidence that the american army that emerges in 39 40 41 is is the product of the rooseveltian new deal it's it's
而且在39、40、41年崛起的美国军队恰恰是罗斯福新政的产物，这绝非巧合。它之所以引人入胜，
fascinating for that their uniform james always goes on and on about how their uniforms are their uniforms are designed to be democratic and look like work clothes and not make you look like a soldier. And the Americans are very much going for this thing that it is a modern army, but that's where they've got to culturally. It's sort of, you know, the armies as expressions of their culture, of the cultures that produce them. You know, you want to know what a society is like, have a look at its army. It's sort of there immediately. And the Americans very much do fall into this. They bring modernity.
是因为詹姆斯总是滔滔不绝地谈论他们的军服是如何设计的——他们的军服被设计成具有民主色彩，看起来像工作服，而不是让你看起来像个军人。美国人非常坚定地追求这样一种理念：这是一支现代化的军队，而这正是他们在文化上所处的阶段。这有点像，你知道的，军队是其文化、是孕育它们的文化的表现形式。如果你想了解一个社会是什么样的，看看它的军队就知道了。它就直接摆在那里。美国人非常符合这一点。他们带来了现代化。
They bring a sort of, they bring a sort of Tyro efficiency to it. There's lots of industrialists, mass production people and car manufacturers advising Roosevelt on how to run his war economy and therefore how to run his operation. Then that feeds into how they run their operational level and then the you know strategic and tactical but what the americans are really
他们带来了一种，你知道的，初生牛犊般的效率。有许多实业家、大规模生产专家和汽车制造商在向罗斯福建言献策，告诉他如何管理战时经济，从而如何管理他的军事行动。然后这反过来又影响了他们如何运作战术战役层面，接着是战略和战术层面。但美国人真正、真正擅长的是学习，他们学习的速度极其之快，并且完全乐于接受新思想，而英国人在这方面或许没有那么擅长。但阿尔，我知道通过收听《我们有办法》，我知道通过听我弟弟滔滔不绝地谈论这些，是的，实际上英国人在工业化杀戮方面非常、非常擅长。噢，是的。
really good at is learning that they learn really really fast and they're completely open to ideas in a way that perhaps british are not quite so good at but al i i know from listening to we have ways i know from listening to my brother who talks about it a great deal yes that actually the british were very very good at killing people on an industrial level oh yeah that that in fact the idea that they were all kind of tweedy ineffectual pipe smokers is incredibly wrong and that um they are you know they win the battle of the atlantic and they you know they they inflict untold carnage on the cities of Germany. And isn't this actually one of the reasons why perhaps the profile of generals in the army is so low, is that actually the key campaigns in the war are being fought in the air and on the sea. And it's on such a kind of level
实际上，那种认为他们都是些穿花呢夹克、毫无用处的烟斗客的观点是大错特错的，他们——你知道的，他们赢得了大西洋海战，而且他们对德国城市造成了难以言喻的浩劫。这难道不是军队中将领的存在感如此之低的原因之一吗？因为战争中的关键战役实际上是在空中和海上进行的。而且那种规模的战斗，
that there isn't really much space for the kind of Nelsonian figure, the individual commander, because it's all about munitions and that kind of stuff. And yet when you do get an electrifying figure, he's able to grasp the reins and turn things around. And completely, you know, this is the Phillips, Pace and O'Brien's big war sort of theory, that basically the Allies win the Second World War at land and it's in the air. The Allies win the Second World War in the air and at sea, and the land battles are sort of incidental. You know, and he runs an economic argument
以至于没有多少空间留给纳尔逊式的人物、那种个人指挥官，因为这一切都关乎军火和诸如此类的事情。然而，当你确实遇到一个电光石火般的人物时，他能够掌控大局并扭转乾坤。完全如此，你知道的，这就是菲利普·佩斯和奥布莱恩（Phillips, Pace and O'Brien）的宏大战争理论，即盟军基本上是在地面和空中赢得了二战。盟军是在空中和海上赢得了第二次世界大战，而地面战役某种程度上只是次要的。你知道的，他提出了一个经济学论点，
because he's an economist, economic historian. He says, well, basically, if you look at, for instance, tank production, the percentage of German industrial production that goes to tanks is 5%, yet we think of the Great Land War on the Eastern Front as the climactic place on the Eastern Front as the climactic place where the blood is spilt and the battle occurs. But he says if this is a war of factories, then actually the Germans aren't spending much of their industrial output on
因为他是一位经济学家、经济史学家。他说，好吧，基本上，如果你看一下，例如坦克生产，德国工业生产中用于坦克的比例只有5%，然而我们却把东线的大规模地面战视为决定性的地方，是流血发生、战役展开的地方。但他说，如果这是一场工厂的战争，那么实际上德国人并没有把他们多少工业产出花在
tanks. They're spending 45% of it on aircraft to try and defend their skies, to defend their factories. That's where they're under pressure. So that's the bit of the war effort that's working. But in the end, boots on the ground are the only, you know, Stalin knew this. You had to have Red Army soldiers in Berlin to end the thing. So just to press you on that, because I was going to ask about Philip Sobrian's argument. So his book, I can't remember if it's called How the Allies Won
坦克上。他们把45%的产出花在了飞机上，试图保卫他们的领空、保卫他们的工厂。这才是他们承受压力的地方。所以那是战争机器中真正在运转的部分。但归根结底，地面部队才是唯一的——你知道的，斯大林深知这一点。你必须让红军士兵开进柏林才能结束这场战争。所以我想就此追问你，因为我本想问关于菲利普·奥布莱恩的论点。所以他的那本书，我记不清是叫《盟军是如何取胜的》
or Why They Won or something like that. And he basically starts that book by saying, you know, the fighting is neither here nor there there the battles don't really matter what matters as exactly as you're saying kind of the graphs of you know shell production or you al you you quote a stalin don't you this is a war of engines it is impossible to have too many of them and the side having the largest number of engines is bound to win yeah i mean could you not argue that in some could you not if i was being really brutal could i not say this is a bit like arguing that football managers matter in the grand scheme of things because obviously a given manager will change the the fortunes of a
还是《他们为什么取胜》之类。他基本上在书的开篇就说，你知道的，战斗根本无足轻重，战役其实并不重要，真正重要的是——正如你所说的那样——炮弹生产的图表，或者阿尔，你引用了斯大林的话，不是吗？这是一场发动机的战争，拥有过多的发动机是不可能的，拥有最多发动机的一方注定会获胜。是的，难道你不能在某种程度上反驳说——如果我说话再刻薄一点，我难道不能说这有点像在说足球经理在宏大计划中其实无关紧要吗？因为显而易见，某个特定的经理会改变一支球队的命运，但从宏大计划来看，在十年跨度里，真正起作用的是你给球员开多少薪水，实际上是你的预算才会决定你赢得多少奖杯，幕后独裁政客的质量、寡头的水平才是关键。难道指挥官和战役——说服我吧，证明地面战役、某个特定的地面战役或特定的地面战役以及特定的指挥官确实对战争进程产生了影响。是的，我想我可以向你证明这一点。我的意思是，1942年的沙漠战场确实是这一切急转直下、随后又一切重回正轨的地方。
team but in the grand scheme of things i over a 10-year period it's actually how much you pay the players it's actually your budget that will affect how many trophies you win it's actually how much you pay the players it's actually your budget that will affect how many trophies you win it's the quality of the kleptocratic autocrat in the background the oligarch do the commanders and do the battles i mean persuade me that they're the land battles that a given land battle or given land campaign and the given commander makes a difference to the course of the war. Yeah, I think I can do that for you. I mean, it's 1942 in the desert that really is the sort of where everything goes wrong and then everything goes right.
而且，你知道的，这正是——詹姆斯和我相当喜欢那种带着刺鼻无烟火药味的陈词滥调。我们在《历史的余烬》中对陈词滥调并不陌生。多米尼克在这个播客里甚至直接用过“战争的阴云”这个词。是的，战争聚集的阴雨密布。我的意思是，它依然存在，不是吗？布伦轻机枪“哒哒哒”的敲击声，诸如此类。
And, you know, it's the sort of thing in, James and I are quite fond of the sort of acrid stench of cordite type cliches. We are no strangers to cliches on the rest of history. Dominic has literally used the phrase clouds of war on this podcast. Yes, the gathering storm clouds of war. I mean, it's still there, isn't it? The woodpecker knock-knock of the brain gun and all that.
1942年是盟军命运具有两面性的一年，因为你在1942年5月遇到了绝对灾难性的局面——加扎拉防线战役，托布鲁克在仲夏节（6月21日）陷落，所有可能出岔子的事情都对英国人不利。是的，最终他们的物质优势会胜出。但你仍然有——我的意思是，我认为，这甚至不是什么伟大的历史英雄史观。这是一种相当实用的英雄史观。你知道的，因为当1942年北非的最高指挥层发生人事更迭时，当奥金莱克被解职，因为他江郎才尽且精疲力竭，他被解职后，迎来了蒙哥马利这位人间使者——因为亚历山大是个相当高贵、经验极其丰富的近卫军军官，他是一个非常迷人、
1942 is the Janus-faced year of fortune for the Allies, because you have this absolutely diabolical situation in May 1942, the Gazala Line battle where Tobruk falls on Midsummer's Day, June the 21st, and absolutely everything that can go wrong is going wrong for the British. And yes, in the end, their material preponderance will out. But you've still got, I mean, I think, I don't think this is even a great man theory of history. This is a sort of reasonably useful man theory of history. You know, because when change comes at the top in North Africa in 1942, when Alexander, when Orkinlek is fired, because he's out of ideas and he's exhausted, and he's fired and he brings in montgomery's this sort of emissary on earth because alex is sort of rather grand terribly experienced guards officer who is very beguiling
圆滑的英国建制派人物，而蒙蒂则是个讨厌的爱尔兰主教的儿子，你知道的——你拥有了英国建制派的所有“硕果”。我的意思是，“硕果”（fruits）这个词或许正合适。你知道的，他们确实产生了影响。事实是，蒙蒂无论如何都是个替补，因为还有另一个人，斯特拉弗·戈特（Strafer Gott），原本获得了指挥第八集团军的工作，结果在他上任的第一天就被击落身亡了。因为德国人以为那是坐在飞机里的丘吉尔。
smooth chap british establishment chap and then monty's this sort of annoying irish bishop's son you know that the you know you've got all the all the fruits of the brit British establishment present. I mean, and fruits is probably the right word. You know, they do have an effect. The fact is, is Monty's the sub anyway, because there's another chap, Strafer Gott, who gets the job of running Eighth Army, who's shot down the day he gets the job and is killed. Because the Germans think it's Churchill in his aeroplane.
这是一种说法。他阵亡了。所以蒙蒂坐着飞机被调了过来，这是一种说法，说他阵亡了。所以蒙蒂被调来当作某种替补。而戈特已经精疲力竭，胜任不了这项工作，他是第八集团军老建制派的一部分，其实也不想要这份工作。所以我认为他会带来不同的结果。他绝对不会产生蒙哥马利与亚历山大在1942年的沙漠战场上所产生的轰动效应。
It's one version of events. He's killed. So Monty's brought in his airplane, is one version of events, that he's killed. So Monty's brought in as a sort of sub. And Gott was exhausted, wasn't up to the job, was part of the old establishment in 8th Army, but didn't want the gig either. So I think he would have made a different difference. He would not have had the electrifying effect that Montgomery, working with Alexander, had in the desert in 1942.
我真的、真的认为个人依然在这样做，能够带来这种改变。你知道的，因为关于破解恩格玛密码的一个观点是，有人说它让二战缩短了几年。我们到底怎么能量化这一点呢？我的意思是，也许蒙哥马利把战争缩短了两周，我不知道，因为毕竟菲利普会认为，无论以什么形式、凭借盟军的胜利，战争最终总会以某种方式结束，而且战斗本身是次要的。但我的书的重点之一是，战斗依然必须发生。你仍然必须说服某人去上刺кан、推子弹上膛、打开步枪保险去杀人。你仍然必须说服他们去那样做，
And I really do. I really, really do think that individuals are still are doing that, are able to make that difference. You know, because one of the things about, for instance, cracking the Enigma secret is that there's one argument. Oh, it took years off the Second World War. How on earth do we quantify that? I mean, maybe Montgomery shaved a fortnight off the thing i don't know but because after all phillips would argue it's going to end somehow anyway with an allied victory of one shape or form and the fighting is incidental but part of the point of my book is the fighting still has to happen you still have to persuade someone to fix the bayonet put a round up the spout take their rifle off safety and go and kill people you still have to persuade them
而你究竟是怎么做到的？这就是我的问题。你知道的，如果你被空降到那里——尽管这是一个不太可能的场景，但我们顺着它假设一下——你作为一名将军，究竟如何说服——你知道的，年轻人，比如斯派克·米利根（Spike Milligan），你如何说服斯派克·米利根？因为你一开篇就写到了他，不是吗？是的，他是50和60年代著名的喜剧演员，写了一系列精彩的书，讲述了在这些战争中作为一个并不那么狂热的战斗人员是什么体验。是的。是的。我的意思是，他并不是个狂热的火炮手。多米尼克，我觉得归根结底，如果士兵们感觉到自己受到了照顾——在英国军队中，当然——军队培养出了一种观念，即士兵们需要的是一种“自己被关爱”的感觉，
to do that and how do you do that that's my question you know how if you were parachuted in i mean it's an implausible scenario but let's run with it how how do you as a general persuade you know young men well spike milligan how do you persuade spike milligan because you begin with him don't you yes famous comic uh in the 50s and 60s who wrote a brilliant series of books about what it was like to be a not very enthusiastic fighter in these wars. Yes. Yes. I mean, he's not a keen gunner. I mean, what it comes down to, Dominic, I think is if men have a sense that they're being looked after, in the British army, certainly, the army develops the notion that what the men need is a sense that they're cared about,
一种他们的生命没有被廉价消耗的感觉。而你通过对他们进行良好的训练来培养这种感觉，这样他们至少对自己的军官有信心，对他们即将投身战斗的方式有信心。他们的信件按时送达。然后你就进入了准政治层面——直到贝弗利报告出台之前，英国军队内部一直存在着一种士气低迷的状态，因为人们并不真正知道自己究竟在为谁而战，你知道的，最近有很多关于这方面的学术研究，探讨贝弗利报告如何在军队动员士兵的过程中发挥作用，
a sense that they aren't spending their lives cheaply. And you engender that by training them well, so they think at least they've got confidence in their officers, they've got confidence in the way they're going to go about doing battle. Their mail comes on time. And then you enter the quasi-political uh thing where until the beverage report comes along there is a morale malaise within the british army because people don't really know what they're fighting for and you know there's been a lot of scholarship about this lately about where where the beverage report fits into how the army mobilized its men
因为毕竟，你知道的，1939年的英国远征军（BEF）是老牌职业军队加上部分地方自卫队。那支军队被打得溃不成军。然后是1940年在沙漠中的职业军队，因为丘吉尔在入侵恐慌期间派出了士兵，我认为这实际上表明了他对入侵恐慌有多么严肃对待。他把他们派往了北非。然后是与此同时集结起来的军队。第一集团军去了突尼斯，那是斯派克·米利根所在的部队，随后基本上在地中海作战。接着是在诺曼底作战的军队，缅甸则发生了一些次要战事，而在缅甸，英国的贡献实际上比看起来要小。
because after all you know there's the british army in 1939 BEF, which is the old professional army plus some territorials. That army gets routed. Then there's an army, a professional army in the desert in 1940, because Churchill sends soldiers during the invasion scare, which I think indicates actually how seriously he takes the invasion scare. He sends them to North Africa. Then there's the army that's gathered in the meantime. And first army goes to Tunisia, which is the army Spike Milligan's part of, and then spends sort of essentially fights in the Mediterranean. Then there's the army that fights in Normandy with incidental stuff going on in Burma, where the British contribution is actually smaller than it appears.
因为毕竟你知道，1939年有英国远征军（BEF），那是老牌职业军队加上一些地方自卫队。那支军队被击溃了。然后，在1940年的沙漠里有一支职业军队，因为丘吉尔在面临入侵恐慌时派出了士兵，我认为这实际上表明了他对入侵恐慌有多么认真。他把他们派到了北非。接着是与此同时集结起来的军队。第一集团军去了突尼斯，也就是斯派克·米利根所在的部队，然后基本上在地中海作战。接着是在诺曼底作战的军队，同时缅甸也有一些零星战事，在那里英国的实际贡献其实比看上去要小。
But basically, there are all these armies running at once. And by the middle of the war, the British army just knows it's got to offer as well as good training, as well as good food. And, you know, Milligan's books are interesting because he never goes hungry the entire time he's in the army, even when they're fighting proper, full-on artillery engagements, which is what he used to do. And he'd go forward into the forward observation post, and he was a signaler, so he really saw action up close. But he never, ever goes hungry, and he never goes out without his fags, and he never a signaler so he really saw action up close but he never ever goes hungry he never goes out without his fags and he never goes without his friends and so this is sort of this is sort of
但基本上，有这么多军队在同时作战。到了战争中期，英国陆军意识到它必须提供良好的训练以及良好的食物。你知道，米利gàn的书很有趣，因为他在军队里从头到尾都没挨过饿，甚至当他们在进行真正的、全方位的炮火交锋时——这也是他过去常做的事。他会向前推进到前沿观察所，而他是一名通讯兵，所以他确实近距离地经历过战斗。但他从来、从来没有挨过饿，他身上也总是带着烟，他从来没有他是一名通讯兵，所以他确实近距离见识过战火，但他从来、从来没有饿过肚子，出门也总是带着烟，他从来没有没有他的朋友，所以这是一种这是一种
mosaic of things that persuade people that they want that they want to fight but you need the complete mosaic and the minute the bit different parts of the picture fall away motivation crumbles and fades and and the reason the book's about officers is because it's down to the officers to make sure the men feel like it's worth doing it is amazing how this dovetails with what we were talking about nelson and his campaigns you know to get to get the men on the ships yeah healthy well-fed and feeling happy and nelson is loved because he loves his men and they know it. Okay, I think we should take a break here.
让人确信自己想要去战斗的各种事物的拼图，但你需要完整的拼图，而一旦这张画的不同部分开始脱落，动力就会崩溃和消退，而且，这本书之所以是关于军官的，是因为这完全取决于军官去确保士兵们觉得这样做是值得的。这真是令人惊奇，这与我们之前讨论的纳尔逊和他的战役是多么吻合，你知道的，为了让水手们上船，是的，让他们健康、吃饱并感到快乐，纳尔逊之所以受爱戴，是因为他爱护他的水手们，而他们也都知道这一点。好了，我想我们在这里应该休息一下。
And when we come back, you mentioned Burma. Perhaps we could talk about General Slim, who is one of the Second World War generals who has a statue outside the Ministry of Defence on Whitehall. So he must be a top general. So maybe we could talk about him and some of your others. So don't go. We're going to be talking about top generals when we come back i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of
等我们回来时，你提到了缅甸。也许我们可以谈谈斯利姆将军，他是第二次世界大战中在白厅国防部外拥有雕像的将军之一。所以他一定是一位顶级将军。所以也许我们可以谈谈他以及你提到的其他一些人。所以别走开。我们回来后将讨论顶级将军，我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《娱乐其余部分》，这是你每周必看的
entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment dot com that's the rest is entertainment dot com welcome back to the rest is history we are with al murray the author of command how the allies learn to win the second world war and al you give us these wonderful pen portraits of these different generals. And Tom suggested we focus in on Bill Slim. And I think that's a brilliant choice.
娱乐新闻、评论、八卦点缀，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及提前获得现场门票，请前往 restisentertainment.com，也就是 restisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》，我们邀请到了《指挥：盟军如何学会赢得第二次世界大战》一书的作者阿尔·默里，阿尔，你为我们生动地描绘了这些不同将军的肖像。汤姆建议我们把焦点放在比尔·斯利姆身上。我认为这是一个绝佳的选择。
Tom and I did a podcast about statues in Whitehall. And we had a little chat, didn't we, about Slim. And in that chat, we said that we knew that you and Tom's brother James on your podcast have strong views about General Slim, who's probably not really terribly well-known to most people who are not Second World War aficionados. So, A, tell us who he was, and B, give us your verdict on the great man. Well, Bill Slim is the chap who wins the war for the British Empire,
汤姆和我曾做过一期关于白厅雕像的播客。我们俩聊了聊，不是吗，关于斯利姆。在那次聊天中，我们提到我们知道你和汤姆的弟弟詹姆斯在你们的播客中对斯利姆将军有强烈的看法，对大多数并非二战迷的人来说，他可能并不是真的非常有名。所以，A，告诉我们他是谁，B，给出你对这位伟人的评价。好吧，比尔·斯利姆就是为大英帝国赢得这场战争的人，
and that's really key, for the British Empire in Burma. The Burmese battlefield is so gigantic. In the retreat in 1942, when the British are caught completely with their trousers down by the Japanese, have absolutely no answers to whether the Japanese are going to fight. They retreat 1,000 miles. So they retreat, you know, a London to Moscow sort of distance. You know, the scale of this place is gigantic.
这真的很关键，为大英帝国在缅甸赢得了战争。缅甸战场是如此之大。在1942年的撤退中，当英国人被日本人打得措手不及、完全惊慌失措时，对于日本人是否会迎战，他们完全拿不出对策。他们撤退了一千英里。所以他们撤退了，你知道的，相当于伦敦到莫斯科的距离。你知道，这个地方的规模是极其巨大的。
Through jungle. Through jungle and on mud tracks and with a Japanese enemy that prizes mobility and does this thing of getting around behind you and cutting you off so that they can steal your supplies because they haven't got any of their own. And there's a terrible disaster on the Sitang River. The Sitang River Bridge is blown while half of one of the big British formations is on the wrong side of the river. It's an absolutely disastrous, chaotic campaign.
穿过丛林。穿过丛林，走在泥泞的小路上，面对着一个珍视机动性的日本敌人，他们会绕到你背后切断你的退路，这样他们就可以抢夺你的补给，因为他们自己根本没有任何补给。锡当河发生了一场可怕的灾难。锡当河大桥被炸毁时，英国主力部队之一的一半还在河的错误一侧。这是一场绝对灾难性的、混乱的战役。
So the scale of defeat in Burma, and, you know, this is all at the same time as Singapore's going horribly wrong as well. In the East, the British have the Indian Army at their disposal, but that's run by British officers. And Bill Slim is an Indian Army lifer to the point where he's written some sort of sub-Kipling fiction about snake charmers and stuff. And, you know, he's a Raj soldier, an Indian army soldier. And the Indian army is a shadow army to the British army. It gets the same budget, the Indian army, Indian government has to spend it. And it's a gendarmerie really.
因此，缅甸战败的规模之大，而且，你知道，这一切都发生在新加坡也遭遇惨败的同时。在东方，英国人可以调遣印度军队，但这支军队是由英国军官指挥的。而比尔·斯利姆是一个把一生奉献给印度军队的人，甚至写过一些类似吉卜林风格的关于训蛇人及其他东西的小说。而且，你知道，他是一名拉吉军人，一名印度军队的士兵。印度军队是英国军队的影子军队。它获得相同的预算，由印度政府支付费用。它实际上就是一支宪兵部队。
And its job is putting down tribesmen in, you know, disputations areas. And they call the expeditions punitive expeditions when they go. So it's like Churchill and his Malacan field force kind of army. Exactly, exactly. And I think one of the things about the Second World War is we see it as the sort of hop-off point for the modern world. But actually, within the army, there's an awful lot of, you know,
它的工作是在诸如争议地区平定部族，你知道的。当他们去的时候，他们把这些远征称为惩罚性远征。所以这有点像丘吉尔和他的马拉坎野战部队那样的军队。完全正确，完全正确。而且我认为关于第二次世界大战的事情之一是，我们认为它是通往现代世界的跳板。但实际上，在军队内部，仍然存在大量的，你知道的，
essentially 19th century thinking still kicking around, especially imperially, especially in how you deal with the cookie tribe or whatever who've risen up against you in the Assam Hills. What you do is you go and burn their villages down. It's all terrible what goes on. But Slim is, he's a First World War veteran. He used to be a teacher.
基本上还是19世纪的思想在兜圈子，特别是在帝国层面，特别是在你如何处理阿萨姆山脉中那些起来反抗你的库基部落或其他什么人的问题上。你所做的是去烧毁他们的村庄。那里发生的一切都太可怕了。但斯利姆是，他是一位第一次世界大战的老兵。他曾是一名教师。
He's from the Midlands. And he's, so he's not a gentleman. He's a player, to use a cr World War veteran. He used to be a teacher. He's from the Midlands. And he's, so he's not a gentleman. He's a player, to use a cricketing analogy. And he is the fellow who figures out how to win in Burma. And Burma's at the back of the queue in terms of resources. So they're not getting the snazzy tanks. They're not getting the snazzy Spitfires. They get their spitfires last
他来自米德兰兹。他，所以他不是一个绅士。用板球的比喻来说，他是一个职业球员。他来自米德兰兹。他，所以他不是一个绅士。用板球的比喻来说，他是一位职业球员。他是那个弄清楚如何在缅甸取胜的人。就资源而言，缅甸排在队伍的末尾。所以他们没有得到华丽的坦克。他们没有得到华丽的喷火战斗机。他们最后才拿到喷火战斗机
essentially in terms of the the theaters the british fighting so aren't able to enforce espirit until quite late in the day but slim figures out how to run a an inclusive army you know the indian army is broken down into its different uh constituent battalions and companies so that you you don't have a preponderance of any one ethnicity in a battalion. And this is legacy of the Indian Rebellion. You don't want groupings who could rise up against you within the army. So you've got different ration scales per unit. So all the different dietary requirements, faintly Shoreditch all this, and different languages, and, and different languages. And, and you also have,
基本上就英国作战的战区而言，所以在很晚的时候才能够树立士气，但斯利姆找到了如何组建一支包容性军队的方法，你知道，印度军队被拆分成不同的组成营和连，这样你就不会在任何一个营中拥有某种单一族裔的压倒性优势。这是印度叛乱留下的遗产。你不希望在军队内部出现可能起义反抗你的集团。因此，每个单位有不同的口粮标准。所以所有不同的饮食需求，有点肖尔迪奇式的这一切，还有不同的语言，以及不同的语言。而且，你还有，
um, uh, you know, quit India going on. So we were talking in the first half about how the, you know, the beverage report comes into the, into the deal for fighting soldiers in, in the Indian army, what comes into the deal is independence. And what, what Slim knows he needs to do is create a, as well as, you know, figure out how much armour he needs, how his supply lines work, how to integrate with air power. He needs to figure out that what he's got to do is offer his Indian soldiers the fact, if they fight this one and defeat the Japanese, who are a terrible imperial threat, then come out the other end of it, there will be independence. And Slim is party to that, that sort of, you know, is part of that creation of an understanding for,
嗯，你知道的，“退出印度”运动正在进行。所以我们在前半部分讨论了，你知道的，贝弗利报告是如何进入到作战士兵的事务中的，在印度军队中，加入进来的交易内容是独立。而且，斯利姆知道他需要做的是创造一个，除了，你知道的，弄清楚他需要多少装甲、他的补给线如何运作、如何与空中力量整合之外。他需要弄清楚，他要做的是向他的印度士兵表明：如果他们打赢这一仗并击败了日本——这是一个可怕的帝国威胁，那么走到这一过程的另一端后，就会迎来独立。斯利姆是其中的参与者，那种，你知道的，是为印度士兵建立这种理解的创造过程的一部分，
for, you know, Indian soldiers, because they need educated men to be officers. And that's what, that's who, you know, and if you're an educated man,
因为他们需要受过教育的人来担任军官。这就是，这就是，你知道的，如果你是一个受过教育的人，
you tend to be, you're sympathetic to independence is the way it's crumbled. And Slim figures out how to beat the Japanese by bringing allied material preponderance to bear, which is the thing we talked about in the first half, that's the thing that means you inevitably win. But you've still got to figure out how to get the Japanese to sort of dash themselves on the rocks of that preponderance. And he's very fortunate that the Japanese
按照这种瓦解的方式，你往往会同情独立。斯利姆通过将盟军的物资优势发挥出来，找出了击败日本人的方法，这就是我们在前半部分讨论过的事情，这就是注定让你获胜的原因。但你仍然必须弄清楚如何让日本人自投罗网，撞击在这些物资优势的岩石上。而且他非常幸运，日本人
tend not to change the way they do things, aren't particularly good at learning from their errors. And you end up with these extraordinary battles where the Japanese will put in a massed infantry attack sort of at the same time every day. And they gather in the same place and they shout, we're coming to get you, Tommy. We'll see you in a minute.
往往不改变他们的行事方式，不太擅长从错误中吸取教训。结果你就会遇到这些非同寻常的战斗，日本人每天几乎在同一时间发起大规模的步兵进攻。他们聚集在同一个地方并大喊：我们来抓你了，汤米。一会儿见。
And so they get shelled remorselessly and killed. And Slim is able to bring the Japanese to waste themselves upon 14th Army, which is fascinating. Because you quote him on this. You say, if the Japanese are allowed to hold the initiative, they're formidable. When we have it, they're confused and easy to kill. Yeah.
于是他们遭到无情的炮轰并被消灭。斯利姆能够让日本人在第14集团军面前消耗殆尽，这太迷人了。因为你引用了他的话。你说：如果允许日本人掌握主动权，他们是 formidable（令人生畏的）。当我们掌握主动权时，他们就会陷入混乱，轻易被消灭。是的。
And that seems to be the essence of, in military terms, his achievement. Yes. He seizes the initiative. Yes, he seizes the initiative yes he seizes the initiative and he and and but has the you know has figured out the means to do so it has the means at his disposal in you know in terms of air power and stuff stuff is that that's a technical military term well it's better than this you know the french word materiel always gets wheeled out yeah to this point like kind of like like, can we not just say material?
这似乎是他在军事成就上的精髓。是的。他夺取了主动权。是的，他夺取了主动权，是的，他夺取了主动权，并且他，并且——但是（拥有）你知道的——已经找出了这样做的手段，拥有可供他支配的手段，你知道，在空中力量之类的事情上——材料，那是军事专业术语。好吧，这总比那个你知道的、总被搬出来的法式词汇“materiel（军需物资）”要好，对吧？说到这个，就像是，就像，难道我们不能直接说“material”吗？
Do we have to say materiel? You know, it's sort of a Napoleonic hangover. So stuff is the Anglo-Saxon word for this. But yes, he figures out how to, but you've got to learn how to coordinate stuff, motivate your chaps to do it, and then get the enemy to do what you want. Although what's striking about Slim is he fights these sort of peculiar, offensive, defensive actions in 1944 uh in phalacohema really in india he gets the japanese to waste themselves on there and then the next
我们非得说“materiel”吗？你知道，这有点像拿破仑时期的宿醉。所以“stuff（物资/东西）”才是这个词的盎格鲁-萨克逊语。但是是的，他弄清楚了如何，但你必须学会如何协调这些东西，激励你的手下去做，然后让敌人按你的意愿行事。尽管斯利姆最引人注目的是，他在1944年——嗯，在印度的英帕尔和科希马——进行了这种奇特的进攻性和防御性行动，他让日本人在那里消耗了自己，然后在第二年，即1945年，他主动出击，进行了一场令人难以置信的运动战，就像……就像德国装甲兵指挥官会引以为豪的那种事情一样，显然是在缅甸乡村开阔地带周围进行横扫式的兵力部署，在丛林中进行了一场常规的、几乎是传统欧洲风格的战斗，这真是太迷人了。他具备做到这一点的适应能力。但是，阿尔，你在关于他的那一章中真正展现出来的另一件事是，事实上，日本人显然是一个可怕的、令人恐惧的敌人，但你指出，真正的敌人是疾病。你在丛林中会遇到这种情况：蚊子、螨虫、苍蝇、括号：肠道疾病的重要机械传播媒介、虱子、跳虫、吸血水蛭、老鼠、恙螨、括号：丛林斑疹伤寒的传播媒介、蜈蚣、蟑螂、蝎子、毒蛇和鳄鱼。
year in 1945 he takes it to them and fights this incredible mobile battle that's like um like the sort of thing of german panzer general would pride themselves obviously sweeping formations around the the open bit of the burmese countryside and runs runs a sort of conventional almost a sort of conventional european style battle in the jungle which is which is fascinating he's he's got the adaptability to to do that but al the other thing that really comes home in your chapter on him is that actually the japanese are obviously a terrible a terrifying enemy but the real enemy, you say, is disease. You have this in the jungle where mosquitoes, mites, flies, brackets, important mechanical carriers of intestinal diseases, lice, fleas, blood sucking leeches, rats, chiggers, brackets, carriers of scrub typhus, centipedes, cockroaches, scorpions, poisonous snakes and crocodiles.
为了保险起见，你还说大象有时也会撞向他们。所以这种感觉，也许这就是为什么斯利姆似乎是……嗯，二战迷们的首选，你知道的，他是他们的偶像，而大多数人甚至没听说过他。事实上，你必须是一个军迷才能欣赏到全貌，因为他真正对抗的是细菌、苍蝇、蚊子之类的东西。是的，是的，是的，他正在指挥，从这个意义上说，这非常像一处古老的、你知道的，旧式的帝国战役，就像1890年代法国人征服马达加斯加那样，三分之二的人死于疟疾什么的，它正是处于那种帝国战役的脉络中。我的意思是，斯利姆从未需要应对的另一件事是，在西北欧战场上涌现出的政治问题，那里的一切都离家太近了。他没有丘吉尔在他耳边喋喋不休地说：“V2火箭正落在伦敦，你能快点赢下这场战争吗，求你了？”他从不需要应付这些。事实上，他处于指挥链的最末端，当他在1944年赢得他的几场大战时，布鲁克和帝国总参谋长们并没有真正掌握他到底完成了什么。他们并不清楚他一直试图做什么以及他是如何实现这一点的。他就是那种军迷心中的人物。
And just for good measure, you say that elephants occasionally crash into them as well so that sense that and maybe this is why slim seems to be the um the second world war aficionados you know he's a he's their man whereas most people haven't heard of him is that actually you have to be an aficionado to appreciate the full scale because really what he's fighting is bacteria and flies and mosquitoes and stuff yeah yeah yes he's running he's and in that sense it's very like an old in you know an old imperial campaign sort of thing like when the french conquer madagascar in the 1890s whatever two-thirds of them die malaria or something it's it's in that it's in that sort of imperial vein i mean the other thing slim never has to deal with is the politics that that that
而且在将军们的将军中，斯利姆经常被推崇备至，但他实际上从未需要应对欧洲战争最后两年中那种极其激烈的政治。在这方面，我认为他非常幸运，因为他专注于他正在做的事情。
emerges in the northwest european theater where everything's close to home he's not got churchill breathing down his neck going there are v2s falling on london could you hurry up and win this please he never has to deal with that in fact he's right at the end of the sort of command chain and when he wins his big battles in 1944 brooke and the chiefs of imperial general staff don't really have a grasp on what he's pulled off. It isn't clear to them what he's been trying to do and how he's achieved it. He is the sort of military aficionado.
所以你有了像斯利姆这样的人，他显然对各种情况有着清醒的认识，并完成了撤退然后管理军队等等这一系列非同寻常的任务。是的，我们谈到了蒙哥马利，蒙哥马利把自己塑造成了一个媒体名人，蒙哥马利知道在沙漠中重建士气是多么重要，诸如此类。你刚才在休息前说过，关于你是如何鼓舞士兵去战斗以及诸如此类的事情。考虑到——所以你的书是关于英国人和美国人的，但我一直在想与俄国人的对比，例如。所以俄国人，他们似乎对……不是非常感兴趣
And very often in the generals general, Slim gets wheeled out, but he never really has to deal with the very intense politics that comes in the last two years of the war in Europe. And he's fought, I think, incredibly fortunate in that respect because he eyes down on what he's doing.
关于，你知道的，他们士兵的士气，这样说算公允吗？我的意思是，还是我太严厉了？因为你给人的印象是，当然，你知道，他们士兵的士气。这样说算公允吗？我的意思是，还是我太严厉了？因为你给人的印象是，当然，你知道，我读过安东尼·比弗关于斯大林格勒或柏林战役的书，你会有这样一种感觉：这些俄国将军只是把数量庞大的士兵投进了一种绞肉机里。是的。相信人数优势最终会胜出，诸如此类。
So you've got somebody like Slim slim who's obviously conscious of the conditions and who's performed this extraordinary task of retreating and then managing his army and stuff yeah we talked about montgomery montgomery made himself a media personality in montgomery knew how important it was to rebuild morale in the desert and so on. And you were saying before the break about the, you know, how you rouse your men to fight and all that kind of thing. And thinking about, so your book is about the British and the Americans, but I'm thinking about contrast with the Russians, for example. So the Russians, they don't appear to be terribly interested
这样说算严厉吗？我的意思是，因为书里没有写俄国人，我在想这是否是因为他们的将军可能没那么有趣，因为他们基本上只是……朱可夫是的。好吧，我认为他们很有趣，但我对阿尔的看法很感兴趣……好吧，不，我认为这是……好吧，这是因为我觉得这是，你知道的，
in kind of, you know, the morale of their men, it's fair to say. I mean, or am I being harsh? Because you get the impression, certainly, you know, the morale of their men. It's fair to say. I mean, or am I being harsh? Because you get the impression, certainly, you know, I've read Anthony Beaver's books about Stalingrad or the Battle for Berlin, and you have a sense of these Russian generals just hurling enormous numbers of men into the kind of meat grinder. Yeah. Believing that the preponderance of human material will out, as it were.
我们进入了“谜中之谜”或类似性质的领域。不过，苏联人在激励他们的士兵时，与英美两国相比，最大的不同在于纳粹就在俄罗斯。是的。他们出现了，并在他们本土散播了炽热的纳粹主义。而且，你知道的，你不需要向人们解释你为什么要进行这场战争。这就是苏联在1941年拥有的巨大优势，你知道，在战争的其余时间里，那就是为什么你必须击败纳粹主义是显而易见的。原因就是纳粹主义，纳粹出现在白俄罗斯、乌克兰和所有这些地方。
Is that harsh? I mean, because you haven't got the Russians in the book, and I wondered whether that was because their generals are perhaps less interesting because they're basically just... Sukov is. Well, I think they are interesting, but I'm interested in what Al... Well, no, I think it's... Well, it's because I find it's, you know,
在某种程度上，德国人在面对英国人时也有类似的问题，那就是你究竟该如何激起人们去对抗英国人？我们之前提到过的区域轰炸——英国皇家空军轰炸机司令部对汉堡进行燃烧弹轰炸的努力，就是激励德国陆地力量去对抗英国的绝佳方式。就像考文垂是激励“汤米（英国士兵的俗称）”的绝佳方式一样。你知道，战略战役到底在做什么的那些宏大画面，会激励地面上的人们。但俄国人有这样一件事，那就是这场战争结束后他们实际上将迎来一次大选。美国人在战争期间进行了一次。俄罗斯苏联政府与历史有着一个约会，不是吗？是大写的H的历史，而不是其他任何东西。
we're into riddle inside an enigma or whatever it is, territory. The main difference, though, that the Russians have for motivating their men, as opposed to British and Americans, is the Nazis are in Russia. Yeah. And they've turned up and they've delivered they've delivered red hot Nazism in their area. And and, you know, you don't need to explain to people what you're fighting that war for. And that's the tremendous advantage the Soviet state has in 1941, you know, for the rest of the war, is that it's perfectly clear why you have to defeat Nazism. And the reason is Nazism, the Nazis showing up in Belarus and Ukraine and all those places.
所以它无论如何一直在沿着这些路线激励它的人民。所以我想，我的意思是，你知道的，苏联内部的文化，你知道的，如果将军们去见斯大林而伤亡率不够高，你就会被指控为没有拼尽全力。所以你也有这种情况在发生，血的流淌是你完成任务方式的一部分。而盟军拥有的是钢铁而非血肉的哲学，你试图做的是利用技术，而不是消耗人员。英国人对这种想法非常敏感。你不想再次失去一百万人，因为你还有工厂要填满。战后你还要拯救经济，诸如此类的事情。那么你会说，我的意思是，我猜最著名的二战将军是隆美尔，他是德国人。
And the Germans, in a way, have a similar problem with the British, is that how do you actually motivate to fight against the British? And the area bombing that we touched on earlier, the RAF bomber commands efforts, firebombing Hamburg, is a fantastic way of motivating German land to fight the British. And in the same way that Coventry is a fantastic way to motivate Tommies. You know, those bigger pictures of what the strategic campaign is doing motivate people on the ground. But the Russians have this thing that's the actual have a general election coming at the end of this war. The Americans have one during it. The Russian Soviet government has a date with history, doesn't it, with a capital H rather than anything else.
是的，当然。那么你会说，相比于隆美尔，英国和美国没有极其著名且光鲜亮丽的将军，这一事实也许反映了产生这些军队的本质上的民主文化？是的，我想是的。我认为我们不知道这些人是谁是一件健康的事。我认为我们没有，我们没有，你知道的，纳尔逊在纳尔逊纪念柱上，那种
And so it's been motivating its people along those lines anyway. So I think, I mean, you know, the culture within the Soviet Union of, you know, generals, if they go and see Stalin and they haven't got high enough casualty rates, you're accused of not trying. So you've got that going on, too, that the blood, the spillage of blood is part of how you do it. Whereas the Allies have got this steel, not flesh philosophy where what you're trying to do is use the technology, not expend people. And the British are very sensitive to this idea. You don't want to lose a million people again because you've got factories to fill. You've got an economy to save after the war and all that sort of stuff. And so would you say that the, I mean, I guess the most famous Second World War general is Rommel, who's German.
那就是军事指挥官崇拜的最高极限了，我认为这真的、真的非常健康。我的意思是，就像我刚才说的，你知道，战争结束后蒙哥马利身上发生的事情的一部分，尤其是鲍勃·哈里斯（注：应为博比·厄尔），你知道的，这些人被报以厌恶的目光，因为看看为了取胜我们不得不做什么，你利用这些人来代表这一点，然后你可以把这一切都归咎于他们，而不是归咎于我们自己，为了，我的意思是，隆美尔是一个引人入胜的典型例子，因为他实际上——倒不是说他有着巨大的冲劲和干劲，但他太糟糕了，考虑到他的后勤状况，他极不擅长知道何时该停下来舔舐伤口并整顿自己。而这实际上正是他在沙漠中被打败的部分原因。
Yes, of course. So would you say the fact that, say, relative to Rommel, the fact that the British and the Americans don't have incredibly famous and glamorous generals is perhaps a reflection of the essentially democratic culture that has produced these armies? Yes, I think so. I think it's healthy that we don't know who these people are. I think that we don't have, that we don't, you know, Nelson on his column is sort of
但他看起来像个有骑士风度的对手，不是吗？所以也许这就是他出名的原因，因为这让英国人觉得他们又回到了某种锦标赛中。是的，但这也是那种情况。我的意思是，在战争的那个阶段，毕竟在沙漠里，周围没有平民，所以你不会砸烂别人的家。你们只是在互相战斗。所以你可以告诉自己这是一场干净的战争。这就像一场海军战争什么的。但当威灵顿被问及谁是世界上最伟大的将军
that's that's as as high as it'll ever go this thing i sort of the adulation of military commanders and i think that's that's really really healthy i mean as i said earlier on you know part of what happens to montgomery after the war is and bob harris in particular you know these people are regarded with revulsion because look at what we had to do to win and you get you use those people to represent that and then you can you can hang it all on them and not on ourselves for you know i mean ronald is ronald is a fascinating case in point because he's actually it kind of not that he's got great dash and great verve but he's terrible at the considering his logistic position he's terrible at knowing when to stop and lick his wounds and sort himself out. And that's really partly what gets him defeated in the desert.
时，他说是拿破仑，他说那是因为他打败了拿破仑。完全正确。所以隆美尔很出色是一回事，但我们打败了隆美尔，是的，当然是这样。那么阿尔，美国人呢，因为我们从巴顿开始，所以你有奥马尔·布雷德利，你有巴顿，巴顿是——巴顿是最好的吗，最著名的吗，他是最好的吗？嗯，他是一位极其出色的军人，他是一个如此奇特的人，因为他真的很想成为美利坚的汉尼拔，他绝对是——不管怎样，惠勒也是。但话又说回来，你看，这就是重点，这就是重点，汤姆，那就是，你知道，当人们从历史中挑选将军时
But he seems like a kind of chivalrous opponent, doesn't he? And so perhaps that's why he's famous, is that it enables the British to feel that they're back in some kind of tournament. Yes, but it's also that thing. I mean, in that phase of the war, after all, in the desert, there's no civilians around, so you're not smashing up people's homes. You're just fighting each other. And so you can tell yourself it's a clean war. It's like a naval war or something. But Wellington, when he was asked who the greatest general in the world
，他们不会，你知道的，拿破仑就是一个典型的例子，拿破仑最终确实失败了，不是吗？我的意思是，尽管……为什么他们不挑选——好吧，拿破仑就是一个典型的例子。拿破仑最终确实失败了，不是吗？我的意思是，尽管……为什么他们不挑选威灵顿？太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。但然后，你知道的，这就叫“预赛不算，
had ever been was Napoleon, and he said that because he defeated Napoleon. Exactly. So Rommel being brilliant is all very well but we defeated rumble yeah that's of course so al the americans because we started with pattern so you've got omar bradley you've got pattern is who's is pattern the best past the most famous is he the best well he is a brilliant brilliant soldier and he's such a peculiar man because he he really wants to be the american hannibal he is absolutely what lose well anyway but then again you see this is the thing this is the thing tom is is that you you know when when people pick and choose generals
决赛才算”之类的事情。是的，是的。我喜欢巴顿的地方，或者说我着迷于巴顿的地方在于，他脱离了常规，你知道的，作为一个历史话题。事物逃逸了，你知道的，
from history they don't you know napoleon's a case in point napoleon does in the end lose doesn't he i mean for all why don't they pick well, Napoleon's a case in point. Napoleon does in the end lose, doesn't he? I mean, for all... Why don't they pick Wellington? Madness. It's craziness. But then, you know, it's that kind of it's the heats that don't count,
他逃离了军事历史。他逃离了某种严肃的学术历史。他逃离了——他逃离了军事历史。他逃离了某种严肃的学术历史。他逃离了——他现身并一溜烟闯入了文化世界，部分原因是由于他去世而得以缺席。是的。所以你说他，他，他是美国将军中的吉姆·莫里森或吉米·亨德里克斯。是的，我想是的。我真的这么认为。是的。你知道的，他在做出任何垃圾事情之前就死掉了。你知道，亨德里克斯在八十年代制作的唱片会是多么糟糕。所以他，
the finals what matters sort of thing. Yeah, yeah. What I love about, or I'm fascinated about Patton is he got off reservation, you know, as a historical topic. Things escape, you know,
他，他某种程度上，他，他占据了一个文化空间，因为有一部关于他的电影。那是美国试图在越战期间摆脱其军国主义文化的一部分，
he's escaped military history. He's escaped sort of serious academic history. He's escaped, he's escaped military history. He's escaped sort of serious academic history. He's escaped, he's present and buzzed off into the, into the cultural world via, you know, partly because he died to sort of absent himself. Yeah. So you say he's, that he's, he's, he's the, the Jim Morrison or Jimi Hendrix of American generals. Yeah, I think so. I really do think that. Yeah. You know, and he killed before he did anything rubbish. You know, the records Hendrix would have made in the eighties would have been horrible. So he,
你知道，诸如此类。所以他脱离了常规。这就是他如此有趣的地方。我不认为他是最好的或最糟的。我认为他，对于这个地位而言他非常迷人，但这在很大程度上存在的原因是因为对于美国听众来说，我们真的对军事历史很感兴趣。
he, he sort of, he, he, and he occupies a cultural space because there's a film about him. That's part of America, you know, trying to lay down its martial culture during the Vietnam war,
收听这个播客的绝大多数人可能对奥马尔·布雷德利一无所知。他们中的许多人甚至从未听说过这个名字。是的。所以告诉我们他是谁。他听起来像是《火线》里的角色。是的。奥马尔·布雷德利在诺曼底登陆时指挥了在西北欧的美国地面部队
you know, and all that. So he, he's off reservation. That's what's so interesting about him. I don't think he's the best or the worst. I think he's, he's fascinating for this position, but that largely exists because of the American listeners, we were really interested in military history.
。我想他的军队大约有一百五十万到两百万人的规模。那么他是勒克莱尔（法兰西自由军）的上司吗？我想，是的，勒克莱尔确实归他指挥。但是，你知道的，他指挥了D日。奥马哈海滩——尽管这是另一期用于拆解神话的播客——但奥马哈海滩是，你知道的，他职责的一部分。奥马哈海滩、犹他海滩，美军的登陆是由布雷德利负责的美国部分。美军在两次世界大战之间规模极小，这其实是个智库。
The vast majority of people listening to this podcast can probably tell you nothing about Omar Bradley. Many of them will literally never have heard those words. Yep. So tell us who he was. Character from The Wire, he sounds like. Yeah. Omar Bradley commanded the US forces on land in Northwest Europe
并肩负着各种各样的课外活动，比如平民保育团，你知道的，这是一个旨在美化景观、建设国家公园什么的“新政”项目，有点像德国的劳动勤务团，但我们尽量不去细究那个，或者有点像苏联的劳改营——如果你是一个美国左翼或者美国右翼，你就会这么描述它。但布雷德利是从那个环境中走出来的，他是马绍尔的人，乔治·马绍尔的人。乔治·马绍尔被任命负责，你知道的——在1939年9月1日被任命为总参谋长。所以他被请来基本上是为了给军队注入活力，因为罗斯福看到了战争聚拢的乌云。他当然看到了。所以，布雷德利是这个新体制和这支民主化的美军的一部分，他们对那些南方花哨的
when the Normandy invasion came. I think his army was something like one and a half, two million people. So is he in charge of Leclerc, the Free French? I think, yes, Leclerc did come under him. But, you know, he ran D-Day. Omaha Beach is, although there's another podcast for dismantling mythos, but Omaha Beach was, you know, part of his responsibility. Omaha Beach, Utah Beach, the American landings are Bradley, the American component. The American army was tiny in between the wars, this sort of think tank, really.
上校们拉拢自己的团不感兴趣，而这正是第一次世界大战中仍在发生的事情。他想要一支民主的军队。他希望军官团里都是最优秀的人，他希望奖励主动性，他希望（你知道的）把每个人都当作平等对待，这也是军队对待他的方式，因为他是一个极度贫困的教师的儿子，凭借奖学金进入西点军校，他和艾森豪威尔以及其他一些人是同班同学。所以布雷德利就是这样一个非常普通的家伙，你知道，这就是为什么我把他和……把他和巴顿放在书里一起写，因为布雷德利，你知道的，这是美国的两个面，对吧？布雷德利是美国梦的化身，而巴顿则是某种镀金时代的军人青年。把布雷德利视为未来，把巴顿视为过去，这种说法是不是太简单化了
And tasked with all sorts of sort of extracurricular things like the Civilian Conservation Corps, which is know new deal project for doing up the landscape build building national parks and stuff a bit like the arbeit steens but we're trying to dwell on that or a sort of soviet work camp which was if you're an american left american right that's how you characterize it but bradley had come through that and was one of marshall's men george marshall's man george marshall was put in charge of the you know uh it was made chief of staff in September, September 1st, 1939. So he's brought in basically to invigorate the army because Roosevelt sees the gathering storm clouds of war. Of course he does. And he, so Bradley's part of this new establishment and this democratized american army they they're not interested in fancy southern
在某种程度上？嗯，这是一个——我想，如果巴顿不是那么擅长投射阴影的话——是的。但巴顿投射了极其漫长的阴影，那种……你知道的雪茄不离口、气势汹汹的将军模式。雷鸣般的诺曼·施瓦茨科普夫。是的。那全都是，
colonels raising their own regiments which is what was still happening in the first world war he wants a democratic army the best people in the officer corps he wants to reward initiative he wants to you know treat everyone as an equal which is how he's been treated by the army because he's dirt poor teacher's son comes in on a scholarship to west point and he's in the same class as eisenhower and a bunch of other people so bradley is this very sort of ordinary chap you know and that's why i got him and him and um pattern in the book together because bradley's you know it's the two sides of of america isn't it it's the sort of the bradley's the american dream chap and then pattern is the sort of gilded youth uh soldier is it simplistic to say that bradley is the future and pattern is
那全都是你所说的巴顿在美国军国主义文化中掀起的尾波的一部分。尽管，正如我们在《我们有对话的方式》（We Have Ways of Making Talk）中所说，如果是1945年之后的事，我就没兴趣了。好吧。所以，阿尔，
the past to some extent well that's a i think had pattern perhaps not been so sort of brilliant at casting a shadow yes but pattern has cast an extremely long shadow and sort of generals in that kind of you know cigar chomping, you know, mode. Storming Norman Schwarzkopf. Yeah. That's all,
就凭这一点。所以，阿尔，借此机会，即将接近尾声。我在读这本书时一直萦绕心头的一个问题是，对于目前乌克兰正在发生的事情，你认为从研究第二次世界大战和指挥学中能得到什么教训吗？或者你可以争辩说情况已经翻转了，对吧？乌克兰是《租借法案》盟友，而不是苏联，而不是俄罗斯，而那个喜怒无常、……功能失调、僵化的独裁政权是俄罗斯，它在垂死挣扎，无力——你知道，做一些它无力贯彻到底的事情。因为这确实看起来——我的意思是，其中一个永恒的主题是，你必须让你的手下快乐，而这正是你书中的所有将军都擅长的，这也是他们出现在书中的原因，而这似乎正是俄国人真正惨败的地方，他们的手下有着——你知道的，他们的士气已经彻底崩溃，而且没有人关心他们。是的，但正如我所说，你知道，如果你想了解一个社会，看看它的军队；如果你想看一个社会的倒影，看看它的军队。你知道，英国军队规模很小，因为我们已经告诉自己我们不再喜欢打仗了。它同时也是极其“觉醒（right-on）”的，总体而言。总的来说，你知道的，昨天有一名女性通过了伞兵团的选拔，即P连选拔，是一名军医，这非常罕见，
that's all part of your patterned bow wave through American martial culture. Although, you know, as we say on, we have ways of making talk if it's after 1945, I'm just not interested. Okay. So I'll,
因为它对体能的要求极其严苛。你必须非常强壮并具有惊人的耐力。所以昨天在英国陆军中发生这件事是一件了不起的事情。在20国（应为20年）前我认为是不可能的，在30、40年前是完全不可想象的，因为这就是我们社会的发展方向。而军队反映了这一点。俄罗斯军队似乎反映了一个不关心底层民众的腐败社会，你知道，如果你有人脉，你可以通过花钱脱身，诸如此类的事情。
on that. So I'll just on that, just coming to an end. It's a question that hung over the whole time i was reading the book is any any lessons for what's going on in ukraine at the moment do you think in the study of the second world war and the command and that kind of well i mean you could argue that it's flipped isn't it is ukraine is the lendlease ally rather than the soviet union rather than russia and the the dyspeptic um uh sclerotic dictatorship is that is russia lashing out unable you know doing things it's
这似乎是——我的意思是，我不是，你知道的，讨厌一概而论，但这似乎是我对俄罗斯现状的印象。所以军队只是这方面的一个简单倒影，而乌克兰……俄罗斯人成功的另一件事是，绝对激发了成为乌克兰人的自豪感。没有什么比被入侵更能为人们做到这一点的了。当然，这也造成了他们最恐惧的事情——一个独立的、非俄罗斯的乌克兰。好吧，非常感谢。
unable to follow through because it does seem i mean one of the one of the abiding themes is that you have to make your men happy and this is what all the generals in your book are good at and that's presumably why they're in the book and that seems to be where the russians are really badly failing is that their men have you know their morale is shot to pieces and and nobody cares about them yeah but i said you know if you want to look at a society look at its army if you want a reflection of a society look at its army you know the british army's tiny because we we've told ourselves we don't like fighting anymore it's also incredibly right on generally Generally, you know, a woman passed parachute regiment selection yesterday, P Company selection, a medic, which is very unusual
所以你的书《指挥》，以及副标题，我想，你知道的，我相信通过这一集已经显露出来了，即“盟军如何学会赢得第二次世界大战”。我的意思是，那是，非常有趣的是，你知道的，那些并非专门为战争做准备的军队，正如你所说，是如何变得非常为战争做好准备的。所以这是一本如此引人入胜的书。我想，你知道的事情可能是，俄罗斯人会——你知道，也许这就是俄罗斯人的1940年，一切都极其糟糕，而他们会弄明白的，但我不知道，因为最引人注目的是，关于第二次世界大战最引人注目的是，本质上是开放的文化——西方更开放的文化——赢了，而
because it's extremely physically demanding. You have to be very strong and have incredible endurance. So it's an amazing thing that that happened yesterday in the British Army. A thing that 20 years ago I don't think would have been possible is completely unthinkable 30, 40 years ago because that's where our society is going. And the army reflects that. The Russian army seems to reflect a corrupt society that doesn't care about the people at the bottom, you know, that you can buy your way out of if you're well connected and all that stuff.
最封闭的文化输了，也许那——也许这与此有关。这也是一件令人着迷的事情。这是我们在《历史其余部分》中经常谈论的事情。这是个人与体制的相互作用。那种从未真正解决过的张力。个体人物到底有多大程度
And that seems to be, I mean, I don't, you know, loathe to generalise, but that seems to be my impression of what Russia's like. And so the army's a simple reflection of that, whereas Ukraine... And the other thing the Russians have succeeded in doing is absolutely galvanising a sense of what it is to be Ukrainian. There's nothing like being invaded to do that for people. Of course, it creates the very thing that they most dreaded, an independent, non-Russian Ukraine. Well, thanks so much.
上重要并能带来改变？我们在特拉法加那一集里的纳尔逊，或者我们在关于他的几集里的亚历山大。事物在多大程度上是由体制和结构决定的？人物有多大重要性并能带来改变，你知道的，我们在特拉法加那一集里的纳尔逊，或者我们在关于他的几集里的亚历山大，事物在多大程度上是由体制和结构决定的？说到这里，在宣传了阿尔的书之后，我的制片人多姆现在告诉我阿尔必须宣传《我们有对话方式》（We Have Ways）。所以，你知道我们从来没做过什么吗？我们从来没有在这些播客中讨论过领导力，讨论过我们制片人的将才。好吧。我的意思是，他们可以。阿尔，你难道没有给他们这本书的副本吗？
So your book, Command, and the subtitle, I think, you know, I'm sure it's come out through this episode, How the Allies Learned to Win the Second World War. I mean, that's the, it's so interesting how, you know, armies that are not particularly geared up for war, as you were saying, become very geared up for war. So it's such a fascinating book. I suppose that, that you know the thing is maybe the russians will you know maybe this is the russians 1940 where it's all going terribly wrong and they'll figure it out but i don't know because the striking thing is the striking thing about the second world war is essentially the open cultures the western the more open cultures win and the
因为，我的意思是。他们已经收到了。至于他们读没读，那是另一个问题。所以，我的意思是。阅读并学习。这就是我们要说的一切。他们需要让他们的部队保持快乐。就是这样。
most closed of the cultures loses and maybe that Maybe that's something to do with it. It's also a fascinating thing. It's something we talk about so much on The Rest Is History. It's the interplay of the individual and the institutional. That sort of tension that is never really resolved. How much do
所以，多姆现在在对我们说脏话。因为你依然，阿尔，你还是没有做宣传。所以，你必须做宣传。这是对你的直接命令，否则你会被枪毙。好吧，我的意思是，你知道的，在诺曼底的一次士气低落期间，前线曾送去淋浴和啤酒来振奋士兵的士气。所以也许这就是他们需要为我们做的事情。我想他们确实需要，是的。
individual characters matter and make a difference? Nelson in our Trafalgar episode or Alexander in the episodes we did about him. How much are things determined by institutions characters matter and make a difference you know nelson in our trafalgar episode or alexander in the episodes we did about him and how much are things determined by institutions and structures talking of which having having plugged al's book i'm now being told by dorm our producer that al has to plug we have ways so do you know what we never did we never talked about the leadership on these podcasts did we the generalship of our producers. Well. I mean, they could. Have you not given them copies of this book, Al?
在《我们有对话方式》（We Have Ways）节目中，这是阿拉曼战役的周年纪念，当然，如果你是个军迷，那就是第二次阿拉曼战役。詹姆斯和我制作了一周关于那场战役的播客，探讨了背景设定、现场布景，然后回顾了第二次世界大战中具有决定性的第一场伟大的英国胜利。
Because, I mean. They've been sent them. Whether they've read them or not is a different question. So, I mean. Read and learn. That's all we should say. They need to keep their troops happy. That's the thing.
我们还与美国历史学家约翰·麦克马纳斯讨论了美国人如何融入这幅画卷，这都挺有趣的。所以我们有一周这样的内容。然后我们有，我们有一周的，我们还有我们的Patreon，类似于你们的王（Wang），我们有我们的、我们的……我们有我们的Patreon，他们称自己为独立连，我们有有声书，作为副业，我一直在朗读绝版的回忆录之类的内容。这本书中的其中一位指挥官是这个叫彼得·怀特的家伙，他在战争快结束时是苏格兰皇家边防团的一名中尉，他的回忆录讲述了他在从瓦尔河到汉堡的经历中的“jocks（苏格兰士兵）”体验，我正在朗读这个。他就是你书《指挥》中最后一位指挥官，对吧？是的。所以现在已经上线了，并将持续到圣诞节，因为这是一部
So, Dom is now swearing at us. Because you still, Al, you still haven't given the plug. So, you've got to give the plug. This is your direct order or you'll be shot. Well, I mean, you know, in Normandy during a morale dip, showers and beer were sent to the front to cheer the men up. So maybe that's what they need to do for us. I think they do, yes.
所以，多姆现在在对我们说脏话。因为你还是没有做宣传，阿尔，你必须得做宣传。这是给你的直接命令，否则你就会被枪毙。我的意思是，你知道，在诺曼底士气低落的时候，前线曾送去淋浴和啤酒来振奋男人们的精神。所以也许这正是他们需要为我们做的。我想是的。
On We Have Ways, it's the anniversary of the Battle of El Alamein, the second Battle of El Alamein, of course, if you're an aficionado. And James and I have done a week of podcasts about that running through the, running through the setting, the scene, and then running through the climactic first great British victory, the second world war.
在《我们自有方法》节目中，今天是阿拉曼战役的周年纪念日，当然，如果你是个狂热爱好者的话，那就是第二次阿拉曼战役。詹姆斯和我做了一周关于这个话题的播客，梳理了背景和场景，然后回顾了第二次世界大战中第一场具有决定性意义的伟大英国胜利。
And we were also talking to John McManus, an American historian about where the Americans fit into that picture, which is all quite interesting. So we've a week of that. And then we've, we've a week of, we've also our Patreon, which similar to your Wangs, we've our, our week of we've also our patreon which similar to your wangs
我们还与美国历史学家约翰·麦克马纳斯谈论了美国人在这幅画面中的位置，这都非常有趣。所以我们有一周这样的节目。然后我们还有我们的Patreon，类似于你们的Wangs，我们也有我们的……我们也有我们的Patreon，类似于你们的Wangs，
we've our patreon and they call themselves the independent company and we have audio books where i've been reading out of print memoirs and stuff as a side project and one of the commanders in this book is this fellow peter white who was a lieutenant in the king's own scottish border at the very end of the war and his memoir with the jocks of his experience of going from Walker and to Hamburg, I'm reading that. And he's the last of your commanders in command, isn't he? Yeah. So that's up now and that'll run till Christmas because it's an
我们有我们的Patreon，他们自称为独立连，我们有有声书，作为副业，我一直在朗读绝版的回忆录之类的内容。这本书中的指挥官之一就是这位彼得·怀特，他在战争快结束时是国王直属苏格兰边防团的一名中尉，他的回忆录讲述了《苏格兰士兵》从瓦尔基尔到汉堡的经历，我正在读这个。他就是你那些指挥官中的最后一位指挥官，对吧？是的。所以现在已经上线了，会一直播到圣诞节，因为这是一个
enormous book. Wonderful. And Tom, for our listeners, we have coming soon two special episodes about treason from the national archives that's brilliant i that was amazing privilege wasn't it we we saw the charge sheet against amberlynn and the court records for charles the first trial it's brilliant yeah fantastic popish plots um excellent lord hawthorne uh bills of attainder from richard iii and all this wasn't a british citizen though was he no he had a passport he fraudulently obtained a british passport and that was what damned him
皇皇巨著，太棒了。汤姆，对于我们的听众，我们即将推出两期关于国家档案馆藏叛国罪档案的特别节目，这真是太棒了，那真是一次令人惊叹的特权，不是吗？我们看到了针对昂布林的起诉书和查理一世审判的法庭记录，太棒了，还有天主教阴谋，出色的霍桑勋爵，理查三世的剥夺公权法案等等，但他不是英国公民，对吧？不，他有一本护照，他通过欺诈手段获得了一本英国护照，正是这一点毁了他。
they'll always get you with the bureaucracy won't they in the end yeah they will so we've got that and then we've got another epic tale coming up the week after that which is uh king alfred's battles against the vikings and that i believe Tom is also rather like the podcast about Al's book. That's also a tie in with a, an absolutely tip top spectacularly good book, isn't it? I don't know. Is it?
官僚主义总会抓住你的，不是吗？最终是的。所以我们有这个，然后我们将在接下来的那一周推出另一个史诗般的故事，也就是阿弗雷德国王对抗维金斯的战役，我相信汤姆，这也挺像关于阿尔书的播客。这也是一本绝对顶尖、极其精彩的书的联动，对吧？我不知道。是吗？
Yes, it is darling. Your new, your new children's book. I can't plug my book. I know. I know. I'm the only one who hasn't plugged the book.
是的，亲爱的。你的新儿童书。我不能宣传我的书。我知道。我知道。我是唯一一个没有宣传书的人。
So I think I, so I think, I think, I think we need to end it now. So thanks very much for listening. Pip pip. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
所以我想我们需要现在结束了。非常感谢大家的收听。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需获取额外节目、提前收听、无广告收听，
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。提前收听、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论的必备节目，
splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
还有一点娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外节目以及优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。